You know what I should do? Listen to
what do you think? I listened to you.
Jealous of the classic jazz and classical
of course. Of course. Yeah. We'll,
you're so interesting.
I was,
I was a concert level violinist until
I was until I was like 17 years old
practice. Yeah. I mean,
the only expensive object that I own
other than my house is his violin.
Oh really? Yeah. Is it a of area? It
is not. It is. It is a up. It's not,
that's all I know. That's a, yeah,
they're the two that people may know
or strat and, and like ordinary. Um,
but those, those ones are like
hundreds of thousands of dollars.
This is in the tens of
thousands of dollars to various
is hundreds of thousands
of [inaudible]. The Guy who we knew, my
family knew hit $1 million Stradivarius.
Oh yeah. Now it was so big about
it was the big deal. Well, I mean,
aside from the historic
value of the thing, they're
not making any more of them.
Um, it does play very
differently, very differently.
Like I had a crappy violin for most of
my are like really until the last two
years.
I had a violin that was handed down
from my grandfather that was worth maybe
1300 bucks and it was a piece of crap.
I mean, it was not a good violin.
If you're good enough,
then you can tell the difference between
a really great violin to play and one
that is a piece of garbage. And I was
good enough to do that. So that's, yeah,
I mean I was, I was a
classical guy. I played,
I played violin for years and
my dad was, uh, growing up,
my dad was a pianist looking
at what Jamie just pulled up
the most expensive violin.
The world sold for an
estimated $16 million.
Yep.
For Australia.
I never lose value. I mean,
really they don't. And this is,
this is a good investment. The person,
I know this guy who was offered a,
he's offered a strategy, I think
it was $250,000 maybe 10 years ago.
And he's like, no, that it's
worth like $3 million today. God,
no.
What is the deal?
Like what if you had to explain what's
the difference between the sound that
this makes sense?
I mean, it has to do with the
acoustics of the instrument.
Any of the wood quality.
There's,
there's slight variations
in the construction of the
instrument is certain parts
of that are thicker or
thinner. Um, and it is also,
it's easier to play a better violin,
so it almost covers for your mistakes.
When you play a, a bad violin, it
tends to scratch and screech more.
That's why when you get in the
upper register with a violin,
you hit very high notes.
It can either be very screechy or it
can be very beautiful. Some of that,
a lot of, most of that's the
player. Some of that's the violin,
like Yasha Heifetz who is widely
considered the greatest violinist to,
to ever live.
He had a Strad and
lady blunt Stradivarius caught
15 point $9 million these
and then they lend them out on, on loan
to, you know, world's great violinist. So,
but there's a, but in the end it really
is the, uh, the quality of the player.
There's a famous Yasha Heifetz story
where he was playing at Carnegie Hall and
some lady came up to him afterward and
she said, you know your violin and just,
it sounds so beautiful. And he picks
up the violin, puts it to his ear,
and he says, funny, I
don't hear it right now.
So do you listen to any other kind of
music? Yeah, I mean, I just, I like,
I like some classic rock. I
mean, see, rocking out. Yeah.
I went to a Doobie brothers
concert with my parents. No,
you did. Yeah. Really? Yeah.
Yeah. That's, that's a band that was
main named after a joint. That is true.
That's how it went. Is accurate.
I know. Did you feel like,
uh, like a sinner? I was,
I was a rebel that day.
That was really gone to the Doobie
brothers concert with the other boomers.
So the.